the latest cbs news battleground tracker
poll in florida shows the presidential
race there tightening in that hugely
important state democratic candidate joe
biden leads president trump by just two
points 48 to 46 percent among likely
voters
that is within the margin of error and
down from six points
back in our last poll in july florida as
you know consistently produces razor
thin margins of victory
and our manuel pojorquez is in key
biscayne just outside miami tracking all
this manny good morning to you
can you say anyone is still on the fence
there in florida
you know what there still are some
people who are on the fence here but as
you mentioned it is always close we do
know this
there is a lot of voter enthusiasm in
this state president trump won florida
by just over one point in 2016 we've
spoken with voters on both sides and
many agree
it's simply too close to call
this honk for trump event in central
florida organizers point to the number
of honks
as proof the president's support is on
the rise judging from what we see
from passing people we get about 90
percent support from passing cars
among white floridians president trump
has a 22-point edge
according to the new battleground
tracker poll of likely voters
i agree with his policies i believe he's
very much more
fit to run this country than joe biden
is personally
you know i agree with what he's done in
the middle east the
the peace deal with israel go vote guys
but to clinch the state the president
may need to win back support
from voters like dave santorelli who's
not sure he'll vote for donald
trump again i don't like how he is on
social media
you know everyone that's against him he
always has to blast them
you know and i don't think that's a
proper way of going about things
in florida the president's signature
style is among the factors costing him
support
sad to see how divided we've become he
didn't unify the nation
you know he should have came on early
said hey we have to wear a face mask
that's the only thing we have
against us right now to help us among
hispanic voters
joe biden has a 20-point edge but still
less than hillary clinton received in
2016.
a group calling itself cubans with biden
is honking horns too
trying to make gains in miami's
cuban-american community
where support for democrats can be a
hard sell
at coco cuts barber shop cuban american
angel alvarez explained
all my family going to vote for trump
maybe he's maybe some maybe he makes
some mistakes
nobody's perfect but to me he's
defending our freedom
our rights we need to be free we don't
want chemists here
we are americans 2017's hurricane maria
which heavily damaged the american
commonwealth of puerto rico
may also impact florida's vote tens of
thousands of displaced puerto ricans
resettled here
and were met by volunteers they had
arrived here
and they have become active part of our
communities
for people gathering to commemorate the
third anniversary of the hurricane in
kissimmee
the emphasis was also on voting we need
to come out and vote
we need to come out this election is one
of the most important for the people
for the hispanic people for the minority
people still
it's the economy that looms large
florida's unemployment rate quadrupled
over the past year
i'm a furloughed person like so many
others in central florida
so yeah we are all concerned on when our
jobs are going to come back
and approximately 20 million visitors
have been kept from coming to florida
since the pandemic began
nearly 33 thousand jobs were slashed in
the hotel and culinary union
it has since hired some of its workers
to stump for biden
can you count on your vote for your
bidding betty garrier says she makes 200
calls a day
and does not know when or if the job she
had as a cashier at the airport
will come back i'm very motivated to
vote myself
and to bring other people with me that's
why i'm calling every day
it's worth noting the economy is still
showing up as a win
for president trump here in florida with
44 percent of respondents
saying he would help their families
financial situation as opposed to 34
percent
who give the nod to joe biden tony
manny thank you very much